the european union has secured more than
two billion doses of covid19 vaccines
meps backed the strategy and called for
more transparency around vaccine
contracts and deployment
people who work from home are twice as
likely to work more than the legal
maximum average of 48 hours a week
parliament called for a law to allow
europeans the right to disconnect
outside of work hours
meps welcomed the inauguration of joe
biden as the 46th president of the
united states
they called for the rejuvenation of eu
u.s ties
and for improved cooperation on issues
such as peace climate change and the
digital world
russian opposition politician alexei
navalny has been jailed for at least
30 days following his return to the
country
meps urged the eu to do more to hold
russia accountable for human rights
abuses
including imposing sanctions on those
involved in navalny's arrest
one in 10 people in the eu are
overburdened by housing costs meps want
access to decent and affordable housing
to be considered a fundamental right